[Music]
there has been a major change involving
Harvey Weinstein if you were wondering
if his wife would stand by and even
though he's accused of sexual harassment
and rape we now have our answer she's
out
Weinstein said today it was his wife
Georgina Chapman decision to separate he
adds I support her decision I am in
counseling and perhaps when I am better
we can rebuild a source tells ET right
now the British fashion designer is
holding up OK Weinstein Mary Chapman in
2007 she's the co-founder of Marchesa
and a Hollywood power player in her own
right is the perfect night for Harvey
Weinstein and his wife Georgina happened
Chapman dresses the a-list
JLo Taylor Swift Halle Berry it's a big
responsibility you know you get cooled
and this someone's big day they're on
the red carpet and they've chosen to
weigh you for that big moment the
couple's wealth has been estimated at
170 million dollars they had two
children
seven-year-old India and four-year-old
Dashiell a source tells us Weinstein is
feeling very desperate and he's
struggling that same source also claims
that Harvey's daughter Lily called
Georgina and told her Harvey is suicidal
this morning police were called to
Lily's home for a disturbance we reached
out to Weinstein's reps but did not hear
back by our deadline meanwhile Weinstein
was snapped in LA today outside the
office of one of his attorneys the
Hollywood mogul is reportedly reluctant
to turn over his cell phone before
entering treatment at an overseas sex
rehab but his team is urging him to
leave as soon as possible today Cara
Delevingne joined a growing list of
Hollywood actresses who say they were
sexually harassed by Weinstein and a
meeting in his hotel room she says he
tried to get her to kiss another woman
and when she asked to leave quote he
walked me to the door and stood in front
of it and tried to kiss me on the lips
while Hollywood has widely condemned
Weinstein's behavior actress Lindsay
Lohan posted a video of support the
georgina Newsies
and be there for husband and he's never
hummed me or there not even to me and
we've done several movies together and
so I think everyone needs to stop I
think it's wrong
Lindsay's publicist deleted the post
Kevin spoke to Oscar winner Cate
Blanchett last night who worked with
Weinstein on the Aviator and Carole any
male who's in a position of authority or
power you know whether he'd be a film
producer or the President of the United
States who thinks it's his prerogative
to sexually intimidate or abuse women
they need to be held to account
more and more stars coming forward
[Music]